the democratic party is terrified of the
idea of joe biden running for president
again because they think he will lose so
they're undermining him obviously but if
it's not biden who would it be who are
the other potential candidates well dana
perino is one of the best people in the
world at thinking this stuff through
she's co-anchor of america's newsroom
co-host of the five a friend of ours
probably a lot of other things too a dog
owner she joins us tonight dan thanks
for coming on so
let's just stipulate that there are a
lot of democrats who don't want biden to
run again nothing personal but they his
approval rating suggests he shouldn't
run again so
if it's not biden who would it be do you
think well do you remember a few months
ago i came on your program and i
suggested to everybody to keep a watch
on hillary rodham clinton because she
was making noise about how the election
was taken from her uh that she would be
uh somebody who could save the party
really now there's three people who are
saying this on the record one is hillary
clinton the other is bernie sanders and
now your friend liz warren
so they all three on the record are
basically saying look if biden chooses
not to run again i will run although
hillary has not said that she's
basically intimated it then there's all
of these people that are on background
and all the mainstream media have you
noticed this tucker it's like um you
know joe biden is leading us to a
terrible place and so then the question
becomes well would it be kamala harris
immediately if joe biden decided not to
run and i predict that if he were to
make that decision it would be the
wednesday before thanksgiving or the
monday after thanksgivings want to be on
record saying that
immediately the question is will you
endorse kamala harris and i think that
is it really in question and unlikely i
think he sees a lot of his son beau
in mayor pete
i also think that stacy abrams if she
were to somehow win the governorship in
georgia she's an automatic entry into
this race jared polis is the governor of
colorado people are kind of interested
in him he would be a way out of the box
choice but a governor would be probably
a better bet for the democrats though i
think that they are in for
not only a bad 2022 but to me it looks
really hard for me to understand how
they would turn it around by 2024. it
feels that it sure feels that way then
there's barack obama who's already
served his two terms of course but he's
emerged to weigh in on like some of the
biggest policy issues of the moment
which foreign presidents don't typically
do do you see any significance in that
well i think part of the things that
we're dealing with now as a country is
that we've never had so many former
presidents still living you know this
long i think jimmy carter has been
hasn't been president since 1980 and you
know he is still with us and although he
doesn't comment on foreign policy as
much as he used to he still likes to
weigh in once in a while president obama
is a young man he's got this uh netflix
deal he's got a spotify deal he's out
there and about and also i think that he
takes umbrage at the idea that
joe biden says that he's the most
progressive president
because barack obama wants that title i
also think that president obama truly
believes that in 2016 had he been able
to be the one running against donald
trump that he would have run and so in
some ways he's like thinking that he is
still the king maker and that joe biden
in 2024 is not going to be in that
position that position i think is still
held by barack obama
yeah i think you're exactly right about
that dana prinno thanks so much great to
see you tonight bye-bye
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight